معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي
ومؤمن نرى عربه اسعاف من خلفك و وهؤلاء
يعملون يعني في ظروف لا يوجد اصعب منها
ربما نعم عثمان ظروف صعبه جدا الوضع قبل
قليل ما حدث عندما قصفت طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مفترق الظهره في غرب مدينه خان
يونس وادى الى ارتقاء حتى هذه اللحظه
ثلاثه من الشهداء واكثر من ثلاث
جريحا الوضع داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي كان
صعبا للغايه لنقص الحاد في الكوادر الطبيه
والتي لا تستطيع التعامل مع الاعداد
الكبيره من الجرحى التي تاتي فقط من غاره
اسرائيليه حده واحده فما بالك بكثافه
الغارات والقصف الاسرائيلي على مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خان يونس في ظل استمرار
الاشتباكات الضاريه والعنيفه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائ رايلي
تحديدا في المنطقه الغربيه والجنوبيه
الشرقيه من المدينه بالاضافه الى المحور
الشمالي الشرقي والشمالي ايضا من المدينه
في محيط منطقه المشروع وحي الامل الاعداد
الكبيره من الاصابات والنقص الحاد في
اعداد الكوادر الطبيه الى جانب انعدام
الامكانيات الطبيه من ناحيه الادويه
والمستلزمات اللازمه لانقاذ حياه الجرحى
الذين يصلون تباعا الى مستشفى ناصر عبر
وسائل نقل بدائيه ومنهم من
قصف في مفترق الظهره القريب جدا
والمتاخر لمجمع ناصري الطبي اتوا سيرا على
الاقدام الى المجمع لا توجد امكانيات
امكانيات معدومه جدا داخل المجمع الطبي مع
استمرار سقوط المزيد من الشهداء وايضا
المئات من الجرحى في مختلف المناطق في
مدينه خانيونس وايضا عدم تمكن حتى سياره
الاسعاف من الوصول الى مختلف المناطق
والحصار الذي تضربه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على محيط مستشفى الامل وجمعيه
الهلال الاحمر و ايضا مركز الاسعاف التابع
للجمعيه هذا كله يؤدي الى كارثه انسانيه
وايضا صحيه في هذه المدينه التي تتعرض
للقصف والغارات الجويه على مدار الساعه
قبل ساعات من الان اجبر جنود جيش الاحتلال
الاف النازحين داخل مدرسه فيصل في المنطقه
الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس اقتحموا هذه
المدرسه واجبروا الالاف على الخروج من هذه
المدرسه بعد التدقيق في هوياتهم واعتقال
عدد من الشبان والرجال واجبار النساء
والاطفال على التوجه الى منطقه المواصي
القريبه من ساحل البحر غرب مدينه خان يونس
ومنهم من توجه ايضا الى هنا الى مدينه رفح
تحت ظروف واوضاع انسانيه صعبه حتى ان هناك
عدد من الجرحى اضطروا ل انتشالهم وايضا
جرهم من تلك المنطقه محيط منطقه فيصل الى
ساحل البحر عبر كراسي متحركه وايضا حملا
على الاكتاف كما رصد الصور من تلك المنطقه
ايضا الاوضاع هنا تزداد ضغطا هنا في مدينه
رفح مع وجود مئات الالاف من النازحين
نتحدث عن اكثر من مليون و500 ال نازح
يتواجدون في هذه المدينه الحدوديه القريبه
من الحدود مع مصر وسط امكانيات صعبه
للغايه وعدم توفر الخدمات الاساسيه حتى ان
المنظمات الاغاثه سواء الامميه او المحليه
هنا تقول ان الاعداد الكبيره من النازحين
والهائل في مدينه رفح فاقد قدراتها على
تقديم المعونات سواء الغذائيه او الطبيه
او حتى توفير المياه الصالحه للشرب فما
بالك بمئات الالاف من المرضى الذين نزحوا
وخاصه اصحاب الامراض المزمنه الذين لا
تتوفر لهم حبه دواء واحده سواء في
المستشفيات او المراكز الصحيه التابعه
للصحه او الهلال الاحمر او حتى في المراكز
الصحيه التابعه لوكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الاونور مؤمن الشرافي من رفح
شكرا جزيلا لك مؤمن